what what's happened is now they've put
this picture out so that you would
assume and i'm somebody who has been and
the press loves to talk about this
especially today i'm somebody that has
been in his office i've seen it this is
not the way his office looks they give
you this appearance that you walk in and
there's these top secret documents just
thrown about hey
they don't understand
something could be marked top secret
could be marked classified the
presidential records act he would have
said this is declassified it doesn't get
a new marking all the time he's left the
office it is a complete public spectacle
and i'm not really going to stand by it
anymore you know i personally have
gotten intimidated people have tried to
intimidate me it's not going to work you
can't just put a picture like this and
say look
did the fbi do that or was that the way
that room looked before they went in
there do you have any any firsthand
knowledge yeah i'm sure you've seen the
press today i do have first-hand
knowledge as you know i have been down
there i'm down there frequently i have
never seen that i have never ever seen
that that is not the way his office
looks anybody that knows
president trump's office he has guests
frequently there it is
it's just a joke they literally must
have gone in and taken out documents
they wanted or cover letters as it is
and put it about so that the public
believes that this is top secret
documents that were on his floor
it's ridiculous i can tell you
personally it's ridiculous i've never
seen that